bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir l'histoire àurissante d'un grand
sociologue et ce sociologue c'est vous
Gérard Brener bonsoir bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être notre grand témoin ce
soir avec exorcisme chez Grasset vous
révélez comment le sociologue de la
raison que vous êtes qui a travaillé
pendant des années sur les fake news sur
le complotisme a succombé dans son
adolescence aux croyances les plus
folles
au chamanisme aux envoûtements au
fanatisme aussi on va en parler à la
tête d'un petit groupe d'illuminés vous
étiez aspirant gourous ça mérite une
explication c'est une autoanalyse qui
permet d'éclairer de façon personnelle
intime aussi le le sociologue
respectecter que vous êtes aujourd'hui à
tout à l'heure dans la deuxième partie
notre grand débat ce soir le
gouvernement a-t-il sacrifié l'écologie
pour éteindre la colère des agriculteurs
entre Bruxelles et Paris Emmanuel Macron
et Gabriel Atal multiplier les annonces
moratoire sur les jachèes POS sur la
réduction des pesticides fin de la
surtransposition et-ce le prix à payer
pour lever les barrages on en parle dans
un instant sur ce plateau avec mes
invités enfin nos affranchis ce soir le
parti prix politique de yel Goose le
billet filo de Nathan de vert et puis
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée bien sûr c'est avec Marco
Pomier qu'on verra ça on y va Géral
Bronner avec plaisir ça vous regarde ça
commence
maintenant
[Musique]
il y aura-t-il un avant et un après 1er
février pour l'agriculture française
après les annonces du président et du
Premier ministre ce soir la FNSEA et les
jeunes agriculteurs les deux syndicats
majoritaires appellent à suspendre les
blocages jacher pesticides
surtransposition on va revenir dans le
détail sur les mesures avec cette
question ce soir l'écologie est-elle la
grande perdante bonsoir benoî mournet
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance des Hautes Pyrénées et
porte-parole de votre groupe hein donc
majoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
bonsoir Christophe grriison bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes agriculteur
céréalier dans l'Oise vous avez aussi du
maréchage mais en circuit court vous
êtes membbres de la coopération agricole
que vous agricole c'est bien ça que vous
représentez vous aurez vous avez aussi
participé à ces mouvements de de blocage
des agriculteurs donc vous les vous les
soutenez pleinement bonsir bonsoir
camill chaise bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes ancienne présidente des Jeunes
Écologistes enfin bonsoir Richard verli
bonsoir Miriam ravi de vous retrouver
journaliste France europeurope au
quotidien suisse blique et visage
familier chroniqueur affranchi dans
cette émission Géral Bronner n'hésitez
pas c'est un sujet évidemment qui nous
concerne tous hein parce que on les voit
tous les jours parfois il nous bloque un
peu les les routes donc si vous avez des
questions si vous voulez interpeller nos
invités n'hésitez pas on commence par
planter le décor comme chaque soir
comment la colère des agriculteurs a
fait plier Bruxelles et Paris c'est dans
le recap de Bruno don qu'on accueille
tout de
suite alors bonsoir Bruno bonsoir Miriam
bonsoir à tous la journée politique a
été dense et vous vouliez donc faire le
point sur ce que vous avez appelé Les
Liaisons dangereuses entre agriculteur
et politique oui alors figurez- vousous
mirriam que c'est le ministre de
l'Économie lui-même qui m'a inspiré
cette idée de liaison ça s'est passé ce
midi
écoutez-le le revenu des agriculteurs ne
doit pas être la variable d'ajustement
des négociations commercial entre les
industriels et les distributeurs Aï
alors j'ai vu dans ce petit dérapage
Malte à propos un symbole celui des
liaisons très contrariées entre les
agriculteurs et le gouvernement car mis
sous pression par la colère paysane nos
responsables ont été contraints de faire
cet après-midi des annonces un brun
surprenantes je vous explique d'abord ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que la colère
était aujourd'hui sur deux fronts en
France d'abord avec des blocages un peu
partout mais également à Bruxelles
devant la Commission européenne tout le
monde en Arab même les citoyens nous
disent dans la rue il tape dans les
mains il nous tape sur les épaules vous
avez raison vous avez raison c'est une
botte de bandit alors côté français
Gabriel hatal a donc pris le taureau de
la contestation par les cornes du trop
plein de nomenclatures européennes et il
a fait lui aussi du trop plein de ses
normes un horrible
myseris l'Europe doit être facteur de
protection et de souveraineté et non
l'inverse il a donc fait des annonces
dont les plus emblématiques sont les
suivantes 1 une mise en pause du plan
contrôle et pesticides 2 des contrôles
de l'origine des produits agricoles dans
les supermarchés et 3 150 millions
d'euros d'aide destiné aux éleveurs VO
c'est 150 he je me permets de corifier
pas 15 millions un peu plus que ça c'est
à vous alors vous vous avez noter ce
dans le rapprochement entre difficultés
des agriculteurs et dictat le le mot est
le vôtre hein de de Bruxelles euh une
surprise disons que j'ai trouvé ça un
peu opportuniste et surtout un peu court
car ce matin le député européen issu
lui-même de la majorité Pascal campfin a
rappelé une vérité et un chiffre très
important sans la PAC sans le transfert
de 9 milliards d'euros dans les cours de
ferme aujourd'hui en France il y a plus
d'agriculture en France voilà sans
l'Europe et ses subventions quick plus
de revenus pour les agriculteurs alors
et bien alors plus que les normes c'est
en réalité la distorsion de concurrence
qui pose problème ici et pour mieux
comprendre je suis allé vous chercher
une séquence elle a été captée lundi sur
un barrage routier regardez ici nous
sommes sur un blocage au niveau de la
Belgique avec nos amis français à juste
à la frontière et ici on retrouve des
œufs provenance d'Ukraine classe a donc
classe A c'est quand même une bonne
classe non conforme alors ce qu'on peut
lire mode d'élevage non conforme aux
normes CE allez avec des normes qui ne
sont même pas légales ça c'est scandal
c'est vraiment scandaleux alors voilà
c'est ça qu'Emmanuel Macron est allé
plaider aujourd'hui à Bruxelles il a mis
la pression sur Ursula van derleyen pour
que les droits de douane des produits en
provenance d'Ukraine soient rétablis
mais c'est pas tout car il s'est
également félicité d'une autre conquête
nous avons d'abord obtenu hier une
dérogation sur les 4 % de jacher et oui
il a obtenu le gel des fameuses jacher
destiné a favoriser la biodiversité
alors le président de la FNSEA a semblé
très satisfait il a d'ailleurs appelé à
lever l'ensemble des blocages seulement
voilà les défenseurs de l'environnement
suivez mon regard eux sont très inquiets
car ils expliquent ce soir qu'Emmanuel
Macron souspression ne se préoccupe plus
du tout d'écologie et ils font la
liaison tiens tiens avec un certain
Nicolas Sarkozy qui en plein Salon de
l'Agriculture avait fini par déclarer
quoi donc je voudrais d'ailleurs au
point où j'en suis dire un mot de toutes
ces questions
d'environnement parce que là aussi ça
commence à bien faire alors le président
Macron est-il en voie de sarkoosisation
la liaison ne doit pas être automatique
mais elle peut tout de même ne pas être
oubliée merci beaucoup merci Bruno donet
pour ce résumé ce billet d'actu toujours
aussi bien bien campé on va commencer
avec l'agriculteur que que vous êtes
Christophe Grison euh entre ce qu'a dit
le président de la République sur les
normes européennes sur BR à Bruxelles la
pose sur les 4 % de jacher l'encadrement
des importations de volaill ukrainiennes
et puis ce qu'a dit Gabriel Atal à Paris
sur les pesticides les successions le
renforcement des contrôles de
l'application égalim de la loi égalim
les 150 millions on en parlait il y a un
instant est-ce que le compte y est pour
vous est-ce que vous considérez qu'il
est temps d'arrêter les
blocages bonsoir euh écoutez
effectivement les intentions sont bonnes
euh effectivement le le syndicat la FSA
et la Coordination rurale ont appelé à
lever les barrages je crois que la
plupart j'ai appelé mes collègues qui
sont sur les barrages encore ce soir
avant de rentrer dans le studio ils
maintenaient le barrage ce soir pour
avoir les écrits demain et en fonction
des écrits ils lèveront le barrage
demain matin parce que il est aussi de
bon ton d'arrêter un mouvement social
pour arrêter d'embêter la population
notre but c'était pas d'embêter les gens
qui au travaill mais plutôt d'embêter on
va dire la logistique euh je pense que
l'opération a été quand même réussie euh
on a bloqué avec 250 tracteurs sur Lain
j'ai été sur le sur le barrage au nord
de Roissy mais on n pas bougé nos
tracteurs notre souhait c'était vraiment
de faire le blocage logistique on
t'entend la volonté d'apaisement dans
dans vos mots mais tout de même c'est ça
veut dire quoi c'est quand même rare de
voir l'Europe bouger aussi vite ça veut
dire qu'il n'y a que les preuves de
force finalement pour obtenir non c'est
pas la question c'est qu'il il y a un
vrai enjeu pour les générations futures
il y a environ la moitié des fermes qui
sont à reprendre d'ici dis ans ça fait
180000 exploitations agricole pour la
France si on ne change pas le
modèle politique économique nous donner
une une trajectoire on a vraiment besoin
d'une trajectoire et bien les jeunes ne
s'intéresseront pas au métier
d'agriculteur et je pense que c'était ça
un peu l'enjeu et effectivement on va
pas se mentir il y a une certaine
lassitude on respecte les normes moi je
suis le premier à respecter les normes
européennes mais c'est vrai que la
France a toujours tendance à vouloir en
mettre un petit peu plus et quand je
vois certains voisins éè pour vous non
c'est pas excès de un peu un peu trop de
norme et quand on voit certains produits
qui rentent chez nous faut savoir que 50
% par exemple des volailles sont
importés en France alors c'est sûr que
le weekend on a plus de prendre un
poulet label mais toute la semaine dans
les épades dans les dans les hôpitaux
dans les écoles on va manger un poulet
àortter des pays de l'Est qui n'a pas du
tout les mêmes normes sanitaires que les
nôtres on vient de voir la démonstration
avec les les œufs pareil on a enlevé
tous les œufs cage en France c'est je
trouve ça normal c'est bien mais du coup
on importe ce qu'on ne voulait pas en
France n'importons pas ce qu'on interdit
en Europe et en France au fond ce
message là il a bien été entendu on
Souha pas opposer l'cologie et
l'agriculture au contraire on est les
premières victimes du réchauffement
climatique on souhaite mettre en œuvre
des pratiques agricoles moiême je suis
président d'une coopérative agricole on
engage nos 1400 agriculteurs pour
améliorer leurs pratiques agricoles mais
là c'est un un petit peu de de ralbol au
question écolog oui la coupe était
pleine on on l'a bien on l'a bien senti
et on l'a senti partout en Europe c'est
ça qui est incroyable Chav lycée
Allemagne France Belgique Espagne
Portugal également Roumanie c'est rare
de voir à part pendant l'épidémie de
covid c'est rare de voir l'Europe bouger
aussi vite est-ce que ça vous a surpris
alors d'abord ça avait démarré au
Pays-Bas vous vous en souvenez ou il y a
quelques mois et effectivement ça prouve
qu'il y a un Malage généralisé en Europe
et aujourd'hui s'est quand même passé
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire
c'était un sommet sur l'Ukraine qui est
devenu un sommet sur l'agriculture là le
tour de passe-p est quand même très
significatif parce que l'Ukraine c'est
une crise majeure pour le continent
européen mais Emmanuel Macron a consacré
quasiment la totalité de sa conférence
de prve que la France pèse encore he par
prve alors ça prouve d'une part que la
France pèse encore par chance le verrou
Victor Orban sur l'Ukraine avait réussi
à être levé au début du sommet donc ça
permet mettait ensuite de parler
d'agriculture ça prouve surtout
qu'effectivement la France a pu
s'appuyer sur un malaise qui n'était pas
que français parce que disons les choses
si les paysans français avaient été les
seuls à manifester ça aurait été
beaucoup plus compliqué pour Emmanuel
Macron d'obtenir les concessions qu'il a
obtenu donc cette solidarité paysane
elle a fonctionné alors sachant que
néanmoins redisons-le les paysans de ces
différents pays n'ont pas toujours tous
les mêmes problèmes il y a en plus une
spécificité française qui est la
diversité de l'agriculture française on
l' vu 12 absolument il il y a il y a des
modèles d'exploitation qui sont très
différents en France d'ailleurs il y a
plusieurs syndicats c'est pas du tout
vrai dans des pays qui ont peut-être un
modèle beaucoup plus agro-industriel et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on reproche à
l'Ukraine d'avoir un modèle
agroindustriel qu'on pourrait presque
comparer à celui des États-Unis ouai
alors peut-on assister peut-on parler de
tournant c'est la question qu'on se pose
un peu ce soir je vais vous faire réagir
beno mournaet manuel Macron veut croire
carrément un changement de modèle un
changement de logiciel en Europe sur les
questions agricoles arrêter d'importer
ce qu'on interdit en Europe écouez le
chef de l'État nous avons tenu de
pouvoir lancer un travail de révision en
profondeur de la logique et de
l'approche européenne d'intégrer le
changement de logiciel dans lequel nous
vivons la guerre est là le monde se
transforme et donc nous devons avoir une
politique agricole plus simple qui
prenne en compte davantage la nécessité
de produire plus qui évidemment intègre
nos objectifs environ maux mais qui le
fait en préservant une concurrence
loyale en préservant le revenu des
agriculteurs et en préservant notre
souveraineté alimentaire c'est ça le
changement de logique que nous voulons
porter au niveau européen que nous avons
commencé ces dernières heures à pouvoir
lancer enclencher et sur lequel nous ne
lâcherons rien alors ça c'est les mots
on veut tout cocher toutes les cases
échanger de modèles beno Monet ce soir
on se dit quand même que s'il y a une
chose qui ralentit voir qui s arê sont
les normes environnementales en France
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
l'analyse les chà chers les 4 % de pour
libérer les champs pour la biodiversité
c'est fini on arrête aussi le plan
écopyo sur les pesticides la réduction
de moitié en 2030 c'est quand même pas
rien ça non alors moi j'ai pas cette
analyse si vous me permettez si on
repart du terrain que nous disent les
agriculteurs sur le terrain il nous
disent on veut vivre de notre travail
premier point ils nous disent on veut
que vous nous simplifiez la vie pas avec
des parfois qui s'empilent et qui se
contredisent et on veut pas de
concurrence déloyale ils nous disent pas
qu'ils veulent sortir de l'Europe les
sur le terrain vous l'aveis dit je vous
en remercie la PAC c'est 9 milliards
d'euros ils nous disent pas non plus
qu'ils veulent s'affranchir de
l'agroécologie parce que c'est la
condition même de la souveraineté
alimentaire et de la survie du modèle
agricole français EUR il nous dit quand
même le chef de l'État qu'on va arrêter
d'être mieux disant sur les normes c'est
bien ça l'idée les néonicotinoïdes vous
les avez voté soit résultat on achète le
sucre à l'Allemagne c'est fini ça je
voulais je suis très à l'aise avec ça
parce qu'il y a quelques mois au mois de
mai on a voté une résolution pour éviter
les surtranspositions qui étaient un peu
une fâcheuse tendance alors soit on
arrive à convaincre nos partenaires de
s'aligner sur nos normes soit on y
arrive pas et à ce moment-là on assume
en France d'avoir un niveau de sécurité
sanitaire et écologique supérieur mais à
ce moment-là il faut être cohérent il
faut acheter français sinon on perd sur
les deux les deux tableaux qu'a voulu
dire le le président de la République il
a voulu dire ce qu'on a porté sur égalim
qui est que le revenu des agriculteurs
est pas la variable d'ajustement que ce
soit porté au niveau européen sur
écofito il est pas question d'arrêter il
est question deune suspension jusqu sal
prier ministre
arrêri le ministre de l'Agriculture pour
évaluer certaines normes qui sont qui
sont illogiques en terme de juste de
simplification et de mise en œuvre je
vous prends un exemple aujourd'hui
promesse tenud qui a été annoncé
vendredi dernier engaron le décret a été
pris sur les cur les curages d'eau sur
les fossées ça correspond à quoi prcis
c'est une une folie de pas permettre aux
agriculteurs de d'entretenir les fossées
puisque derrière ça peut générer des
inondations je vous prends un autre
exemple sur le pastoralisme que je
connais bien dans les dans les montagnes
des Pyréné mais qui se pose aussi dans
les Alpes on on s'est battu et on a
obtenu au niveau national et et européen
une simplification des règles de tir de
défense c'est pas l'agriculteur contre
l'écologie le pastoralisme c'est
l'entretien des paysages sont des puits
d'eau ce sont des puits de carbone et je
vous le dis d'autant plus à l'aise que
on est dans le Sud-Ouest une agriculture
plutôt paysane et même un peu pauvre sur
certainsent vous me dites que ça fait
bon ménage on peut pas les opposer
n'empêche que ce soir camillechaz le
pacte vert le fameux Green Deal il est
un peu entaillé non il est ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que les députés
européens ont mal travaillé n'ont pas
compris les pays
d'Europe je pense que Emmanuel Macron
quand il nous dit qu'il veut un égal
européen euh montre un peu l'incohérence
de tout ça parce qu'on a eu enfin on a
eu égalim en France qui n'a rien donné à
ce stade pour la rémunération des
paysans et des paysannes donc en fait
c'est toujours des effets
d'annonce le groupe renew en Europe a
voté pour la PAC à ce moment-là n'a pas
jugé bon de remettre en cause ce modèle
aujourd'hui on nous dit oui il faut tout
revoir on va tout remettre à plat mais
dans les faits vous auriez pu le faire
il y a déà quelques
années pour moi la question de des
pesticides c'est vraiment un gros recul
pour les agriculteurs pour les marier la
patronne des écologistes sur la pause
sur écopyo dit le gouvernement peut
décider de ne plus protéger l'eau la
terre la biodiversité et même notre
santé mais avec ça nos agriculteurs ne
gagneront pas plus voir il gagner en
fait il y a une étude du CNRS avec
quelquesines d'agriculteurs sur des
milliers d'hectares pour pour montrer
justement les conséquences d'une baisse
de 50 % des
pesticides et en fait on s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait pas d'effet sur le
rendement par contre vu que on achetait
moins de pesticides il y avait une
meilleure rémunération pour les paysans
et les paysanes donc en fait pour moi
ces mesures sur enfin contre l'écologie
c'est juste une instrumentalisation
depuis le début de cette crise des des
paysans et des paysannes parce que en
fait le début de cette mobilisation
c'est le revenu de ces paysans il y a
beaucoup de revendications le revenu
évidemment cette question des normes
elle était centrale vous comprenez
qu'elle puisse être subit comme des
contraintes quand le voisin en Europe
même pas seulement à l'étranger en
dehors des frontières de l'Europe ne les
applique pas ne les a pas mis en en
application par des lois donc ça vous
comprenez quand on est écologiste qu' a
un sujet là-dessus ou ou pas bah il faut
bien évidemment ne pas importer des
produits des produits qui seraient
fabriqués trait
avec des des substances illégales en
Europe évidemment en tant qu'écologiste
évidemment on lutte contre ça mais on
pense aussi qu'il faut aller plus loin
en Europe sur ces questions-là c'est une
question de biodiversité c'est une
question de pollution de l'eau c'est une
question de santé des consommateurs mais
également des agriculteurs eux-mêmes qui
subissent aujourd'hui des cancers et
cetera à cause de ces produits et c'est
une question aussi d'avoir un peu la
corde au coup de devoir sans cesse
utiliser ces produits parce que la terre
devient moins fertile et cetera et ils
n'ont plus d'autre choix que de
continuer de les utiliser et donc nous
on pense qu'il faut non pas arrêter du
jour au lendemain par contre il faut
planifier la sortie de ces substances B
mon non je pas vous contredir là-dessus
puisque dans le budget nous avons voté
sur 3 ans 4 milliards d'euros pour aider
les agriculteurs dans cette transition
écologique il faut les accompagner
làdessus les agriculteurs déjà ne font
plus un assolement unique un exemple
concret parfois d'absurdité après avoir
planter il faut faire ce qu'on appelle
des couverts végétaux et les
agriculteurs ils sont tout à fait
d'accord pour le faire puisque ça
régénère la terre c'est un coup pour eux
quand même mais s'il pleut par exemple
s'il pleut pendant un mois comme c'est
arrivé et bien vous faites pas le
couvert par définition ça ne servirait à
rien et bien l'agriculteur est
sanctionné donc là c'est une dérogation
locale c'est pour ça que les niveaux de
réponse il sont au niveau européen au
niveau national au niveau local contre
des normes parfois rigide qui s'applique
uniformément et qui correspondent pas à
la réalité de nos terroirs et donc dans
cette crise il y avait des
revendications communes mais si on veut
répondre et répondre bien et
efficacement il faut accepter de
descendre dans les territoire pour avoir
des approches différenciées la montagne
vit en effet de subvention de la pâac
les céréaliers de toute façon ils seront
un cours mondial donc c'est pas le sujet
les sujets c'est plutôt l'eau
l'irrigation l'élevage de plaines et de
côau et bien moi je défends une
agriculture paysane qui doit rester avec
aussi des des labels de qualité il y a
il faut pas opposer les agricultures
mais par pié ne dites pas qu'on oppose
écologie et agriculture ce n'est pas
vrai voilà je vraiment et je croisc ce
soir sont vraiment vout les pesticides
c'est de la biodiversité il y a quand
même une chose qui qui m'interpelle
Gabriel hatal sans la nommer s'attaque
aux agences sanitaires la fameuse ans
agence
indépendante sortir d'une situation
ditil où notre agence sanitaire interdit
une mollécule avant qu'elle ne soit
interdite en Europe est-ce qu'il
faudrait revenir sur l'indépendance de
ces agences est-ce que au fond ces
autorités non élues prennent des
décisions qui asphyxient les
agriculteurs alors ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'Emmanuel Macron a quand même est
quand même confronté à une situation
assez paradoxale et ses pères chefs
d'État et gouvernement vont lui rappeler
c'estàd qu'au fond les principaux grifs
sont adressés à l'administration
française c'est quand même ça ou aux
agences françaises le Premier ministre
le reproche de surtransposer de ne pas
prendre les bonnes décisions et cetera
et Emmanuel Macron à Bruxelles explique
que au nom de ces difficultés là il va
falloir rebattre les qu les cartes
européennes disons-le ça ne va pas
passer Emmanuel Macron lorsqu'il
prononce cette conférence de presse dans
la salle juste à côté à Bruxelles il y a
le chancelier Scholz qui lui ne parle
que de l'Ukraine donc c'est pour vous
dire que tout le monde n'est quand même
pas sur le même niveau mais
fondamentalement sur la question des
agences je crois qu'on est en train de
se rendre compte qu'en France
l'administration peut-être appr pris
trop d'initiativ mais qui la dirige
cette administration pardonnez-moi c'est
quand même le gouvernement et depuis
quelques années Emmanuel Macron est au
pouvoir donc à un moment donné ce qu'il
dit il se regarde dans un miroir et il
doit quand même admettre que ça n'a pas
marché en l'occurrence quand elles sont
indépendantes ces fameuses autorités
administratives elles prennent des
décisions qui s'imposent au aux
représentants de la de la nation
Christophe Grison sur les
phytosanitaires c'est vrai qu'on en
parle beaucoup on nous reproche de pas
faire des d'efforts mais je peux vous
dire deux chiffres on a sans soustance
de moins que mes voisins étrangers et on
a baissé de 21,6 % l'utilisation des
phytosanitaires en 5 ans donc on est sur
la trajectoire de l'objectif des mois 50
question c'est qu'à 27 si on doit avoir
les mêmes normes environnemental la
Pologne ne voudra jamais avancer la
Roumanie non plus donc en fait si on
prend pas un peu les dev devent est-ce
qu'on va pas niveler par le bas
systématiquement ces norm ah ben pour
l'instant on nivelle par le haut parce
que justement la France est plus
exigante d'où le ralbol général des
agriculteurs qui disent mais on peut pas
être mieux disant que nos voisins nous
la France on s'est engagé dans des
signes de qualité et c'est très bien
seulement aujourd'hui le consommateur
qu'est-ce qu'il regarde le prix le prix
le prix surtout dans un contexte de
forte inflation Géral Brunner il y a il
y a deux choses qui sont insupportables
pour nos agriculteurs c'est premièrement
le double standard qu'on vient d'évoquer
c'est-à-dire on ne peut pas imposer à
nos agriculteurs des normes qu'on
n'imposerait pas des produits qui
viendraient au nom de quel argument je
veux dire c'est même pas du favoritisme
pour nos agriculteurs il y a aucun
argument rationnel et deuxièmement
certains de nos agriculteurs aussi
doutent parfois de la rationalité des
normes qui sont imposées parce qu'il
faut voir que ces normes sont parfois la
conséquence de lutte de lobbying
intellectuel que ça soit dans les médias
ou à Bruxelles avec avec des ONG et
cetera je connais pas bien ces sujets là
mais justement on s'y perd sur les
retenus d'eau et cetera on narrive plus
à trouver les bons arguments on a parlé
de l'INS et cetera mais combien de fois
lanes n'a pas été écouté alors qu'elle
disait qu'un produit n'était pas
vraiment dangereux qu'il y avait une
probabilité de risque et cette cette
évocation de sécurité de probabilité de
risque était amplifié par des ONG et qui
trouvaient complésamment à à parler dans
les médias parce que il y a comme ça une
attraction pour de notre cerveau pour
bah toutes les informations fondées sur
la peur le risque et donc moi-même je
dois dire ces questions m'intéressent
mais je m'y perd c'est SR c'est extrêch
que dire des de nos concitoyens quoi
l'an je crois que non c'est important
que des agences restent indépendantes
c'est une question de confiance que soit
pas dépendant d'un pouvoir politique et
et sur qu' puisse édiicter des avis sur
des normes sanitaires ou
environnementales mais le sujet c'est
que l'agence nationale l'c soit bien
articulée avec l'agence européenne c'est
d'ailleurs c'est le même sujet sur
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché des
médicaments or aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui
se passe la
sutosaisies de d'autorisation qui sont
étudié et qui on sont déjà commencé à
être étudiés au niveau européen donc
c'est là où on veut un peu réarticuler
réarticuler les choses donc ça je crois
que c'est de c'est vraiment de bonne
politique et donc c'est pas moins
d'Europe en fait c'est plus d'Europe
vous prenez l'exemple sur l'eau si on
veut produire si on veut être souverain
vous serez d'accord qu'il faut de l'eau
il faut arrêter de dire que c'est les
agriculteurs qui consomment de l'eau
c'est nous autres quand on mange qui
consommons de l'eau quand on achète un
Mor
desliication un raccourcissement des
déis deours
cont aussi parce que on a mené ce qu'on
appelle des concertation sur le le cnro
pour s pour s'accorder sur des projets
d'intérêt général et quand ils sont
d'intérêt général qu'on puisse les mener
à bien sur le multi-usage sur des par
exemple des retenues cinaires or parfois
l'entrepeneur retenues cinaires dans si
vous avez si vous avez des des recours
sur ces ces choses ou sur une extension
de bâtiments pour engraisser pour
conserver la valeur ajoutée chez nous et
que vous avez pardon de le dire certains
de vos amis parfois qui font des recours
et qui décourage à 1 2 3 ans c'est pour
ça qu'on a voulu simplifiers sur les
mégabassines en clair on pourra les
construire plus vite et les recours
contre ces mégabacines qui sont
totalement de droit seront les délais
raccourcis c'est contreproductif ces
mégabacines en fait on fait croire aux
gens ça va régler leurs problèm je parle
pas des mégamacines je parle des retenus
cinaires c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose mais bon on n pas le temps tout
développer c'est pas pareil vous le
savez je crois en tout cas euh pour moi
il y a une question
sur toutes ces normes toutes ces
décisions qu'on veut prendre soi-disant
pour améliorer la rémunération des
paysans et des paysannes mais il y a
quand même une chose qu'on n' pas évoqué
là ce sont les marches que se font les
industriels la grande distribution on ne
voit aucune mesure euh là il y a un
renforcement des des contrôles il va y
avoir des agents et et même des
sanctions il y a déjà trois grands
groupes qui ont été sanctionné on on va
laisser le bénéfice du doute on va
attendre et on verra si ça bouge ou pas
c'est vrai plusurs années la loi n'a pas
été bien respectée jusqu'à présent je
voudrais qu'on parle desacord de libre
échange parce qu'on a parlé dans
l'Europe s'il vous plaît juste sur les
prix parce que Monsieur disait les
consommateurs regardent le prix le prix
le prix mais effectivement mais en fait
on voit que les prix pour les
consommateurs ils ont augmenté de 14 %
alors que le prix d'achat pour les
agriculteurs il a il a diminué de 10 %
donc où va cet argent en fait c'est ça
le nœud du problème c'est les les normes
et et moi je veux bien admettre
peut-être qu'il y a beaucoup trop de
paperass à faire pour les paysons et
paysannes d'ailleurs c'est pas que en
lien avec des normes
environnmentales le libre échange de
manière générale qui fait des normes au
profit des industriels et donc nous ce
qu'on dit c'est il faut des prix
plancher il faut un juste prix pour que
les agriculteurs vivent de leur travail
jusqu'on ne leur achète pas leur
production je crois que tout le monde
est d'accord sur sur le sujet mieux
respter égalim on va parler des accords
de libre échange mais peut-être Richard
verli au fond on parle de concurrence
libre et non faussée c'est la fameuse
expression au sein des 27 si on enlève
la question des normes la pomme
polonaise par exemple elle a des
pesticides qu'on n pas nous mais la
pomme polonaise elle sera toujours
beaucoup moins cher le coût du travail
sera toujours beaucoup moins cher donc
est-ce qu'on peut être encore dans la
concurrence libre et non faussée même si
on a tous les mêmes normes alors
peut-être pas toujours parce que
l'objectif de l'Union européenne c'est
quand même à priori un mieux 10 ans
social rappelons-le quand même en tout
cas si ça aboutit à un moins 10 ans
social on a un grand problème ce qui est
vrai c'est qu'effectivement il y a des
distorsions de concurrence au sein de
l'Union européenne et c'est un problème
dans tous les domaines pas seulement
dans l'agriculture parce qu'il y a deux
types de distorsion celle que vous
évoquez Myriam lié aux conditions de
travail au niveau des salaires et il y a
aussi les législations les grands
groupes agroalimentaires ont des
bataillons de conseillers juridiques qui
travaillent à trouver les vides et les
trous dans les législations des
différents pays pour y installer par
exemple leur centrale d'achat ou tel
autre partie de leur groupe et ça c'est
un réel problème on en a beaucoup parlé
vous vous souvenez à l'époque de la
fiscalité les paradis fiscaux ou les
pays qui profitaent de la fiscalité des
autres et bien surûr l'agriculture c'est
la même chose il est clair que tant
qu'on a'ura pas une uniformité des
règles au niveau de l'Union européenne
dans des secteurs aussi sensibles pour
la souveraineté que l'agriculture on
aura des problèmes allez gros plan pour
terminer sur le mercosour ce fameux
traité de libre échange en négociation
depuis presque 10 ans entre quatre pays
d'Amérique du Sud et les 27 inacceptable
pour Emmanuel Macron la France a-t-elle
les moyens de stopper les négociations
et que dit que prévoit cet accord
explication Clément
per le Mercosur est une zone de libre
échange qui ne concerne pas toute
l'Amérique du Sud mais seulement quatre
pays l'Argentine le Brésil le Paraguay
et l'Uruguay programmé depuis 2019 ce
deal avec l'Union européenne prévoit
chaque année pour les quatre états
sud-américains une suppression des
droits de douane sur 100 0000 tonnes de
sucre 180000 tonnes de volaill 60000
tonnes de riz 45000 tonnes de miel 25000
tonnes de viande porsine et des taxes
réduites sur 100000 tonnes de viande
bovvine c'est ce point précis qui est le
plus controversé les grosses
exploitations d'élevage sud-américaines
sont une concurrence redouté elles
bénéficient de surface considérabl et
sont soumises à moins de normes
sanitaires environnemental la France
sous la pression de ses agriculteurs
bloque aujourd'hui les négociations et
réclame des clauses miroires pour
imposer une réciprocité des normes on
demande simplement que les règles
environnementales et sanitaires qu'on
impose à nos agriculteurs et à plusieurs
autres professions et bien soit les
mêmes du côté justement des pays à qui
on est en train d'ouvrir nos portes
sinon ça n'est pas juste il n'est pas
question pour la France d'accepter ce
traité c'est clair c'est net et c'est
ferme mais la France paraît isolée sur
ce sujet plusieurs capitales européennes
jugent cet accord essentiel en
particulier Berlin l'Allemagne voit d'un
bon œil les exportations facilité pour
ces industries automobiles et
pharmaceutiques la France pourtant
pourrait-elle aussi trouver son intérêt
l'accord prévoit de détaxer les
exportations de produits comme les
fromages le
lait mais aussi le vin et les spiritueux
pour ce secteur le Mercosur est
aujourd'hui un marché pratiquement
anecdotique cet accord offrirait donc de
nouveaux horizons les syndicats
agricoles le reconnaissent la France
agricole ne peut pas se passer de
continuer à échanger qui imagine demain
la viticulture concentrée sur le marché
national c'est sa fin programmée et
immédiate on peut aussi avoir des
intérêts offensifs sur le Mercosur je je
ne le ni pas alors que les négociations
arrivaient dans leur dernière ligne
droite la réticence de la France est un
sérieux coup de frein pour la signature
définitive de cet
accord Richard Berli et beno mournet
pour terminer la France a vraiment les
moyens de de stopper net les
négociations elle peut pas les stopper
mais elle a vraiment les moyens de
mettre pour l'instant au frigo cet
accord oui mais il y aura des
conséquences c'estàd qu'on peut dire non
mais vous pensez bien que l'Allemagne
dira peut-être demain non sur d'autres
sujets qui sont importants pour la
France et d'autres pays de l'Union
européenne il y a toujours un compromis
un équilibre à trouver donc oui Emmanuel
Macron peut dire non demain aura-t-il
encore les moyens d' AC la
contreofensive que mèneront
inévitablement ses partenaires européens
on résume souvent cet accord
grossièrement à bœuf brésilien contre
voiture allemande c'est vraiment la loi
de la jungle ce mercous vouons dans les
accords de commerce c'est que ce soit
alimentation contre alimentation le CTA
figurez-vous que l'Europe est gagnante
on exporte plus de matière alimentair
qu'on en importe il est pas possible
d'importer du bœuf aux hormones pourtant
autorisé au Canada sur le sol européen
ça c'est un bon accord de commerce le
mercosour en l'état ce n'est pas un bon
accord de commerce en particulier pour
la filière sucre et pour la filière
bovine nous nous y opposons le sujet
sont pas le problème des accords de
commerce la viticulture aujourd'hui on
consomme moins de V en France en effet
il faut avoir ce déboucher pour le
fromage pour le lait et même
figurez-vous qu'on exporte du porin en
Chine de libre échange il faut il faut
que ce soit miroir il faut qu'il y ait
les mêmes règles pour tout le monde je
crois que c'est ça la ligne que on va
s'arrêter sur un sur un accord vous êtes
évidemment j'imagine tous les deux
d'accord là-dessus non mercosour close
miroir réciprocit danst actuel des
choses oui oui c'est pareil pour les
écologistes CAN éidment et également
contre les autres accords qu'on signé
renu à savoir celui avec le Chili ou la
Nouvelle-Zélande en tout cas ils ont
voté pour on est contre les accord de
libre échange qui ont les mêmes
résultats Mercosur particulièrement mais
également les autres et d' grâ à les
manifestation qu'on a montré les
importations de sucre ukrainien qui
produisent avec des normes différentes
on s'arrête là merci c'était très clair
on s'arrête sur un accord au moins sur
le libre échange je crois que vous êtes
d'accord on peut réconcilier les
agriculteurs les écologistes c'est
possible merci à vous d'être re sur LP
restez AC moiéral Bronner dans une bonne
dizaine de minutes les parties pr de nos
affranchis ce soir Go nous dit pourquoi
la crise agricole et bien a sonné le
coup d'envoi de la bataille des
européennes de quoi l'uniforme est-il le
nom ce sera dans le billet de philo de
Nathan de vert et puis quel est le MEN
de Bourbon Express ce soir Marco Pomier
à peine arrivé gabrielal a déjà sur le
dos une motion de censure doit-il
trembler je vous dis ça dans un instant
à tout à l'heure messieurs mais d'abord
on va plonger dans votre histoire Gérald
broner et elle est je le disais
stupéfiante exorcisme votre dernier
livre chez Grasset c'est un peu la suite
des origines pourquoi devient-on qui
l'on est c'est vous répondez très bien à
cette à cette question vous le
sociologue respectez de la
rationalité vous qui avez plongé jeune
homme dans l'aventure ésotérique et même
un peu dans l'endoctrinement un exercice
passionnant de franchise on voit ça dans
l'invitation d'elzamondangava interview
je juste
[Musique]
après si on vous invite Gérald Bronner
c'est pour revenir sur une histoire à
peine croyable vous nous la racontez
dans exorcisme votre dernier livre
l'histoire d'un jeune homme qui bascule
dans les croyances occultes et ce jeune
homme c'est vous
oui vous gerérald Bronner le professeur
de sociologie membre de l'Académie des
technologies membre de l'Académie
nationale de médecine vous qui avez
publié l'empire des croyances la
démocratie des crédules vous révélez
avoir vous-même un temps céder aux
sirènes du mystique j'étais très radical
dans mes croyances je n'en ai d'ailleurs
jamais jamais fait secret puceque à
plusieurs reprises dans des interviews
j'ai expliqué que probablement ma
passion pour l'objet croyance en tant
que sociologue venait des racines
profondes de mon adolescence et et et
jeune homme simplement je naavais pas
encore expliqué pourquoi jeune homme
Annan si dans les années 80 vous vous
passionnez pour le taekwendo et vous
guêtez l'Apocalypse place Stanislas avec
un groupe d'amis vous fondez le cfles
chercheurs en réalisme
fantastique dans votre livre vous
racontez l'envoûtement et le
désenvoûtement une expérience côté pile
et côté face qui vous permet d'analyser
au mieux les mécanismes du fanatisme
d'ailleurs Gérald Bronner une question
ce soir est-on mieux averti quand on a
soi-même succombé aux croyances les plus
folles alors réponse Gérald Brunner ben
je crois que oui effectivement
d'ailleurs il y a une technique qu'on
utilise beaucoup en psychologie en
sociologie à propos des fake news c'est
ce qu'on appelle la technique de
l'inoculation le prébonking ça se dit en
anglais le debonking c'est la
démissification voyez et donc le
prbonking c'est de bah de confronter
notamment souvent des jeunes à des
fausses informations ou à des théories
du complot qui sont un peu outré de
sorte que quand ils vont rencontrer des
vrais par exemple sur les réseaux
sociaux et ben ils vont se méfier un peu
plus c'est comme le vaccin vous inocule
un tout petit peu de compl s'ppelle la
théorie d'inculation il a été facile à
écrire ce récit franchement ça a été
facile de raconter ça au plus grand
nombre que vous avez écu au surnaturel
que vous avez connu de l'intérieur le le
mécanisme de l'endoctrinement d'une
certaine manière ce qui était difficile
c'est de de de dire oui de de me mettre
à écrire et quand j'ai je me suis mis à
écrire j'ai été un peu saisi par un par
un par une sorte de flot il m'a fallu
quelques mois quand même je suis pas du
genre à écrire comme ça en 2 semaines
certains auteurs le font moi j'ai pas
cette ce feu là il m'a fallu une année
je dirais pour écrire ce ce ce récit
mais j'ai pris à la fois du plaisir et
c'est un peu aussi une souffrance parce
que ça m'a ça m'a bah avec un peu de
mélancolie ramené à à une époque à la
fois bénite et maudite en quelque sorte
il y a du regret de la mélancolie de
cette périodement ou forcément parce que
quand on a cru très fort c'est comme un
amour he quand on a aimé très fort et
que c'est crroyance se retire il nous en
reste toujours quelque chose d' comme un
membre amputé alors rambau Binon vous
grandissez donc dans la bon lieue de
Nancy dans les années 80 vous venez
d'une famille aimante populaire
clairement modeste mais qui vous chérit
vous n'avez pas vraiment souffert de vos
origine modeste votre mère femme de
ménage un père mécanicien deux livres à
la maison seulement la réparer des télés
en fait réparit des télés euh la Bible
est un et un livre sur les
extraterrestres est-ce que vos parents
étaient un peu versé dans l'irrationnel
déjà pas vraiment enfin c'était je je
bénis dans un dans un milieu de folklore
populaire c'est on se racontait des tas
d'histoires les adultes adorai raconter
ça au moment de de de l'apéritif et nous
les enfants on voulait absolument
écouter ces histoires mais le soir venu
on regrettait de les avoir entendu mais
par exemple mes parents ne sont pas
religieux j'ai moi-même je suis pas
baptisé et euh c'est vrai il y avait que
deux livres chez moi mais ça voulait
dire surtout qu'il y avait pas de livres
en fait deux livres bah la Bible comme
dans beaucoup de familles françaises de
l'époque et puis un curieux petit
bouquin sur les extraterrestres oui
parce que mon mon papa s'intéressait
quand même un petit peu à à ça mais
c'est pas lui qui m'a disons communiqué
cette fille bah parce que B il est parti
quand j'avais 6 ans donc on va venir
d'ailleurs à cet oncle qui va vous
ouvrir sa caverne jeune ado vous ne vous
sentez pas vraiment à votre place comme
tous les ados d'ailleurs vous cherchez
euh le jeune homme que vous êtes attire
l'attention en basculant dans la petite
délinquence vous vous devenez ce que
vous dites un businessman c'est quoi un
businessman à cette époque là CIT le nom
qu'on se donné dans les années 80 pour
dire que on était des délinquentss on
faisait du business quoi voilà c'està
dire du vol et cetera c'est plutôt de la
micro délinquence quant à moi et je
raconte aussi d'ailleurs qu'on avait il
y avait pas de marché c'estàd qu'on
avait des objets des autoradios
notamment on volit des autoradios à
l'époque mais on ne savait pas qu'il les
vendre donc en fait il y avait une offre
mais pas de demande donc c'est vraiment
pas par appé c'était chamb un appétit
non du gain mais du symbolique c'estàd
qu'on voulait être un petit peu des des
des des voyou pour se faire respecter et
moi ça m'allait pas j'essaie de jouer le
jeu bien entendu c'est pas du tout vot
nature à l'époque déjà et pourtant vous
vous allez à la castagne hein vous vous
vous bagarz on est bien obligé quand
pour le coup là pour le coup on devient
d'un milieu populaire si on veut pas
être une une victime et j'ai pas c du
tout ce tempérament même si j'aime pas
la violence on est obligé de se se se
battre d'ailleurs je je tous mes amis se
sont déjà battus j'ai couvert bien plus
tard en devenant professeur d'université
et en fréquentant des gens qui avaient
grandi dans la bourgeoisie que c'était
possible de ne s'être jamais battu de sa
vie ce qui me paraissait invraisemblable
alors vous vous cherchez en fait vous
cherchez à combler un grand vide
intérieur qu'on a souvent à
l'adolescence mais chez vous c'est
vraiment fort cette espèce de de
mélancolie de grand ennui vous vous
confessez même à votre plafond qui vous
regarde à travers un une sorte d'œil et
et celui qui va remplir le vide c'est
Jean-Luc votre oncle qui habite dans
l'appartement du dessous dans le même
immeuble que vous dans la banlieue de
Nancy qui sait Jean-Luc exactement euh
vous vous vous vous découvrez quand il
l'autorise sa grotte à quoi ça ressemble
oui ben c'est le frère de ma mère qui a
tout simplement vécu toute sa vie chez
sa mère donc chez ma grand-mère il a été
incarcéré en quelque sorte à vie il
s'est autoincarcéré il aurait pu faire
d'autres choix euh il est mort donc
vieux garçon et et le peu d'argent qu'il
avait parce qu'il en avait pas beaucoup
il le consacrait à acheter des livres
des bandes dessiné des disques il
écoutait France Culture par exemple donc
tout cela je l'ai découvert oui vers 11
12 ans et puis plus tard ensuite avec
lui et je je c'est un peu mon dealer de
de de culture et je sentais quand
j'écoué par exemple France Culture la
nuit parce que j'avais le droit de
découcher j'avais j'étais dans une
famille très libérale donc à 12 ans
j'avais le droit de ne pas dormir de la
nuit si si j'avais envie et j'avais
collège le lendemain mais ça m'apportait
beaucoup et on écoutait donc par exemple
ces radios je suis pas sûr que je
comprenais mais en tout cas j'avais le
sentiment que c'était là mon pays
c'était mon pays de destination et il
vous fait découvrir à la fois la musique
la BD les Beatles Brell flu glacial les
surréalistes aussi et puis les ouvrages
fantastiques le monde merveilleux et
fantastique de Tolkien le seigneur des
anneaux ça ça vous a marqué
particulièrement ah complètement ça
reste encore mon roman préféré
aujourd'hui en c'est celui qui me l'a le
plus marqué je disais aussi Lovecraft
genen beaucoup cétait mon mon mon entrée
dans la littérature je dirais d'abord
fantastique mais en dehors du collège
parce qu'au collège on lisait des des
livres aussi mais là je l'ai lisais par
plaisir ce que faisait pas beaucoup de
mes camarades à à à l'époque et puis et
puis il y avait pas que cette
littérature fantastique il y avait aussi
et bien des livres d'ésotérisme
d'occultiste parce que il s'intéressait
beaucoup à l'histoire secrète des
Templiers et cetera donc peu à peu bah
j'y ai mis moi aussi mon nez h c'est là
que ça se radicalise et que ça bascule
euh dans la construction d'un monde
parallèle c'est vraiment ça le CF les
chercheurs en réalisme fantastique avec
vos amis du TA kwendo avec nail qui est
très important dans dans le récit
décrivez-nous ce petit groupe ben c'est
d'abord c'est d'abord deux personnes naï
et moi on fait du Tew 2 ensemble et
c'est quelqu'un qui cher à mon cœur
c'est comme un frère je l'écris et je
dis aujourd'hui je l'ai encore vu il y a
il y a quelques jours il habite Paris
maintenant comme moi il est devenu
comédien et et scénariste et donc bah
tous les deux parce qu'on ne rêve jamais
vraiment tout seul c'est pas possible
d'essayer de plier le monde à ses désirs
tout seul parce que le monde répond non
de toute façon il nous a répondu non
aussi mais on l'entend moins bien ce non
quand on est beaucoup et donc comme on
était des jeunes hommes je pense un peu
charismatiques à cause du sport de
combat et puis parce qu'on s'intéressait
à des choses un peu bizarres on a vite
réuni vite en un an ou deux une
soixantaine de de galopins enfin nos
mères aussi ils sont rentrés dans le
mouvement donc il y avait pas que des
enfants donc on en fait on entraînait
tout ce qu'on pouvait à rêver avec nous
et peu à peu C au départ sur les
pouvoirs parano normaux la projection
astrale mais on a commencé à voir des
drôles de signes dans la ville de Nancy
qu'on inventait pas des des sortes de
gravures sur le palais du CAL dans la
cathédrale et on a découvert la la
symbolique et il nous a semblé et c'est
là où nous avons commence à nous
fourvoyer dans le fanatisme que ces
signes annonçaient la grande Histoire
l'Apocalypse la fin des temps et on
était bientôt persuadé que la fin des
temps allait arriver à Nancy et
qu'évidemment on allait jouer un rôle
important dans cette histoire parce que
ceux qui qui vous annoncent ce genre de
chos imaginent toujours qu'ils sont un
peu élus pour cette histoire là ouais en
fait vous venez un peu fétichiste de
tous les siges vous avez des des
chiffres ou des nombres magiques c'est
très très étrange hein quand même c'est
en vooutement vous entendez les sabots
des chevaux vous parlez au fit vous
allez même jusqu'à sortir de votre corps
il y a un exemple vous voyez partout
l'ermite la carte du vieux sorcier au
tarot qui vous poursuit partout oui
alors je tiens à dire dire que je ne
suis jamais sorti de mon corps j'ai
essayé pendant des années des années
mais malheureusement le merveilleux ne
voulait pas de moi mais donc j'ai jamais
triché si vous voulez je précis
j'attendais j'attendais que le
merveilleux se manifeste mais il s'est
pas manifesté et dans toute cette ce
bric à brac j'ai cru parce qu'on me l'a
dit parce que des Carum anciennes me
l'ont dit que j'étais envoûté et bientôt
une figure imaginaire d'un vieil homme
qui regardait le sol et qui avait une
cam donc une figure un peu
inquiétante a commencé à remplir ma vie
parce que certaines prédictions qu'on
m'avait faites se sont réalisé par
hasard bien sûr mais comment pouvais-je
imaginer que céit un hasard et le plus
incroyable dans cela j'aurais j'ai pas
le temps de développer j'invite à à lire
mon livre pour en savoir plus c'est que
nous l'avons trouvé ce vieil homme
évidemment nous l'avons inventé nous
avons mis un si vous voulez un postitte
sur un vieil homme qui ne demandait rien
du tout mais qui était un vieil homme
très connu à Nancy parce qu'il tenait un
un très un très grand magasin disons et
qui portait le nom d'un d'un roi et on a
imaginé qu'il était à la tête d'un
groupe sataniste et beaucoup de gens
nous donn des informations bref tout ça
c'est une convergence d'indice on était
pas F on ne croit pas sans preuve voilà
vous dites qu'on vous étiez pas fou ça
c'est très bien intéressant parce que
c'est aussi le sociologue qui écrit et
c'est ça qui est très intéressant dans
ce récit qui est un acte de franchise
hein mais qui aussi un acte de réflexion
dans dans le récit vous vous mettez à
voir des coïncidences extraordinaires
partout vos désirs deviennent des
prémonitions puis des savoirs et ça vous
l'analysez comme un troisème œil qui
vous regarde oui c'est c'est d'Ille
d'ailleurs la motivation principale pour
avoir écrit ce livre c'est pas juste
raconter des notre histoire de club des
CIN c'est un peu une histoire de Pier
nicllé quand même j'espère que c'est
assez drôle en même temps que
mélancolique mais assz pitoresque voilà
je pense que c'est pittoresque comme
vous le dites mais en même temps je
pense que il y a quelque chose
d'exemplaire dans dans mon histoire qui
peut servir justement bah de d'exemple
et au-delà de ça il y a une charge
universelle dans ce que je raconte parce
que je pense qu'on a tous en effet versé
dans des croyances aussi petite
soit-elle parler de l'amour finalement
une forme de croyance le Père Noël et
cetera ou bah les convictions politiques
et puis on a tous été déçus c'est un peu
aussi un récit de la déception et
comment s'en sortir bien de cette
déception c'est aussi une façon
d'éclairer mon obsession pour les
croyances collectives en tant que parce
que vous racontez bien que le
désenvoûtement c'est la deuxième partie
du livre commence avec la sociologie
l'université mais vous avez gardé le
goût du sens caché et ça c'est fou quand
même gerérard Bruner vous avez glissé le
titre de votre futur livre dans
exorcisme absolument oui bah ça c'est le
c'est un peu vous aimez ça hein les
lesésotérisme en fait hein bah disons
que dans ma quête de l'imaginaire je me
suis aussi j'en parle pas beaucoup dans
le livre je me suis beaucoup intéressé
au jeu de rôle et dans le jeu de rôle on
est un peu taquin si vous voulez on on a
un esprit ludique et donc effectivement
dans chacun de mes livres il y a des
souvent des petites énigmes cachées et
et et dans ce cas de figure il y a en
effet le titre de mon prochain livre que
je suis en train d'écrire je vous dirai
donc pas pas qui oui j'imagine bien mais
en est en en même temps effectivement je
je le la leçon que je tire de tout
ça pour expliquer que je sois devenu un
sociologue des croyances mais je ne
pratique pas n'importe quelle sociologie
la nature même de ma sociologie est
inspirée finalement de ces racines
adolescentes parce que j'ai appris que
cette époque qu'on peut croire à des
choses folles mais sans être fou
soi-même vous avez eu raison d'y
insister on ne croit jamais sans raison
en réalité et ce que j'essaie de montrer
c'est mon propre millefeuille
argumentatif et dans fond presque tous
les livres que j'ai écrit j'en ai écrit
un sur les coïncidences ce n'est
absolument pas pour rien j'ai aussi
écrit
desi sur ces sujets évidemment et en
fait oui je je je découvre grâce à mon
éditeur Christophe Bata qui m'a commandé
ce livre finalement une cohérence plus
grande encore que celle que j'avais
imagine il faut lire exorcisme chez
Grassé ou comment un croyant fiévreux va
devenir un grand sociologue c'est un
exercice un peu de d'autoanalyse
d'égoistoire d'une certaine façon vous
restez avec moi Gérald Brunner c'est
l'heure de retrouver nos affranchis pour
leur parti prix ils vont d'ailleurs vous
faire réagir on les accueille tout de
suite
y Goos de franceinre bienvenue à vous
parti prix politique Nathan de vert
plaisir de vous retrouver pour le billet
philo installez-vous on commence comme
chaque soir par le bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée c'est
Marco premier qui sicle ce soir bonsoir
Marco bonsoir myiam Ce soir je vous
raconte l'histoire de la 90e motion de
censure de la 5e République ce sera
lundi motion de censure spontanée
déposée par les quatre groupes de la
gauche pour faire tomber le gouvernement
de Gabriel hatthal raison invoquer le
nouveau Premier ministre s'est affranchi
du vote de confiance à l'Assemblée après
sa déclaration de politique générale
mardi rappelons qu'il en a le droit
critiqué pour avoir déposé cette motion
avant même d'avoir écouté le discours du
premier ministre la gauche se justifie
le Premier ministre nous a privé d'un
vote de confiance donc nous suscitons un
vote de défiance et puis en réalité il y
avait pas beaucoup de surprise dans ce
qu'il allait dire on connaî
la politique de ce gouvernement depuis
2017 et le président de la République a
fait une conférence de presse qui a fait
office de discours de politique générale
c'est le seul moyen de savoir qui est
dans la majorité et qui est dans
l'opposition on le saura grâce au vote
lundi bon Miriam on va pas faire de
suspense en exclusivité je peux déjà
vous annoncer que cette motion de
censure ne sera pas adoptée il faudrait
289 voix pour faire tomber le
gouvernement mais clairement là le
compte n'y est pas les républicains ne
prêteront pas leur voix à la gauche le
rassemblement national ne le fera
probable pas non plus
écoutez la maladie de la motion de
censure systématique et automatique je
trouve que c'est tout à fait contraire à
nos institutions n voterons pas la
motion de censure des insoumis parce que
nous ne partageons en rien la vision des
insoumis on a compris les républicains
ne feront pas tomber le le gouvernement
au lundi mais ils en rêve encore il
menace de le faire un jour c'est ça
exactement c'est ça c'est la menace en
tout cas que certains députés les
républicains brandissent on me confirmé
aujourd'hui que le sujet avait été
clairement posé sur la table mardi en
réunion de groupe menace formulé très
clairement par Olivier marlex devant
Gabriel hatal c'était mardi dans
l'intérêt du pays Monsieur le Premier
Ministre tâchez de faire mieux que ce
qui vous a demandé par le président et
souvenez-vous que la durée de vie de
votre gouvernement ne dépend pas que du
président de la République mais aussi de
cette Assemblée nationale où vous êtes
minoritaire et dont vous n'aurez pas la
confiance voilà alors le gouvernement de
Gabri Atal est-il en surcis
rappelez-vous he l'année dernière la
motion de censure contre la réforme des
retraites à l'initiative du groupe lot
avait été voté par le rassemblement
national par l'ensemble de la gauche et
par 19 députés les républicains il
manquait neu voix neuf petits voix pour
faire tomber le gouvernement c'est donc
bien les républicains qui pourraient
faire pencher la balance à l'avenir
aujourd'hui un député LR me disait avec
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
et la duplicité de Macron sur le texte
immigration nous aussi nous nous
réarmons des décidément ce terme est à
la mode en ce moment aujourd'hui un
nombre plus important de députés LR
pourrait aller dans ce sens encore
faudrait-il un myiam que la gauche vote
la motion de la droite donc ça fait
beaucoup de conditions beaucoup de si
bref pour l'instant c'est le statu quo à
faire à suiv ouais vous regardez ça de
près peut-être qu' bien s il y a aussi
des élections qui leur fait un peu peur
en cas de dissolution si le gouvernement
tombe merci beaucoup Marco la politique
toujours il y AG la campagne des
élections européennes du 9 juin prochain
au fond est déjà lancé parce que
derrière les campagnes il y a la
campagne électorale la crise agricole
révélateur et accélérateur desclivages
d'avenir oui tout l'intérêt des crises
Myriam c'est qu'elle chamboule les plans
de bataille écrits trop vite établis
trop tôt il y a 2 semaines si vous aviez
posé la question à à n'importe quel chef
de parti politique alors quand et
comment est-ce que vous allez mener
cette campagne des européennes
invariablement il vous aurait répondu oh
là là on a on a le temps on n'est pas
pressé on fera ça on fera du blit creak
au dernier moment le plus tardivement
possible campagne la plus courte cible
vous remarquerez que le parti
présidentiel Renaissance et ses alliés
n'ont même pas encore la moindre tête de
liste mais cette année l'actualité a
rattrapé les stratèges avec ses
tracteurs en philadienne à Berlin devant
la porte de brandbourg image virale
parmi métisme la colère s'est propagée à
une grande partie de l'Europe jusqu'à
chez nous ralbol dirigé contre Bruxelles
mais colère transnationale c'est
intéressant le mouvement social dépasse
les frontières pour obtenir de l'Europe
une autre politique paradoxalement c'est
a dit aussi à quel point l'idée
européenne l'espace public européen
avance même si c'est à coup de crise
mais revenons chez nous ce RAL bol des
gilets verts est immédiatement investi
ou récupéré par les forces politiques
qui vont jouer gros le 9 juin prochain
alors à qui à quoi vous pensez
exactement orn favori des sondages à
cette tte de LCE Jordan Bardella qui qui
a bondi sur l'occasion reçu à Matignon
il y a 2 semaines il demande à Gabriel
Atal l'état d'urgence agricole puis il
fonce dans le MOC et le weekend dernier
c'est Marine Le Pen dans le Nord qui
monte sur un tracteur image contre image
Gabriel Atal débloque un barrage en haut
de Garonne son pupitre est une botte de
paille car cette crise agricole est un
condensé de tous les mots max du moment
pouvoir d'achat environnement
souveraineté alimentaire commerce
équitable géopolitique avec l'Ukraine et
c'est pour ça que Gabriel Atal dans son
baptême du feu et Emmanuel Macron le
vétéran du discours de la Sorbonne n'ont
pas voulu laisser le chaos s'installer
ils ne pouvait pas se louper partage des
rôles donc ce jeudi on l'a bien vu
journée décisive à Gabriel Atal les
concessions nationales à la mi-journée à
Emmanuel Macron le bras de faire
européens en fin de journée notamment
sur les jachers et l'accord du Mercosur
mais là vous ne parlez que duurn et de
renaissance c'est c'est pas un duel
cette campagne j'ai bien conscience mais
force de constater que dans cette
pré-campagne c'est ce duel qui
réapparaît et qui écrase tout intérêt
des deux camp des deux camps bien
compris hein les écologistes subissent
la vague antinorme raphaë glusman
n'existe que pas ou très peu sur le
sujet les républicains inventent l'usine
à gaz d'un revenu agricole minimal qui
serait financé par la suppression de
l'aide médicale d'État on comprend plus
rien et l'histoire retiendra que c'est
Gabriel Atal dans les dernières minutes
de son discours de politique général
mardi qui a des facto enclenché la
campagne en ciblant directement le RN et
son frxit déguisé au-delà du match
au-delà des grandand box cette
précampagne cette campagne dans le prê
nous oblige tous les uns les autres à
mettre le né dans la politique
européenne dès maintenant ses forces ses
faiblesses ses dispositions ses
transpositions l'Europe tu l'aimes ou tu
l'aimes plus mais qui peut croire qu'il
la quitte merci beaucoup et on l'
commencé à le faire dans notre premier
débat d'ailleurs de se plonger dans les
questions européennes on va pas échapper
à ce face à faceace il est organisé
d'avance vous pensez Gérald broner le
gouvernement Renaissance face au
rassemblement national l'Europe plus
d'Europe ou moins d'Europe c'est ça
c'est ça le scénario il est écrit
d'avance oui c'est vrai que la crise la
crise là avec les agriculteurs tente à y
faire penser je suis assez d'accord avec
ce qui a été dit mais je mettrais quand
même un petit Joker sur l'intérêt qui
aura regarder à gauche sur ce qui va se
passer sur sur ces élections européennes
personne ne le sait je pense justement
c'est peut-être là où il y a le plus
d'incertitude et donc peut-être là où ça
sera le plus intéressant de regarder
parce que ça annonce peut-être la suite
on verra et elle il y a un espace pour
la gauche avant la crise agricole
c'était il y a eu ces quelques jours de
glxman Mania c'est une de journaux c'est
quand même retombé assez vite avec c'est
vraièm constion listes c'est loin d'être
réglé ils sont pas d'accord sur qui on
met derrière glman et puis les
écologistes veent aller en solo Olivier
fort op PS a dit ma porte sera ouverte
jusqu'au 17 mai pour faire une liste
commune on n prend pas le chemin Nathan
devevert pour terminer vous vouliez nous
parler de l'expérimentation de
l'uniforme l'expérimentation et la
tentation de l'uniforme tentation à
laquelle la France est en train de céder
lentement en janvier dernier lors de sa
conférence de presse Emmanuel Macron a
annoncé que partir de septembre prochain
septembre 2024 une centaine
d'établissements publics allaient
expérimenter l'uniforme établissement
volontaire et si cette expérimentation
était saluée et que les choses se
passaient bien entre guillemets et bien
à partir de 2026 il serait envisageable
que l'uniformes s'étendent
potentiellement à la totalité des
établissements publics entre-temps on a
vu des photos de ces potentiels
uniformes qui ont été dévoilés donc ce
sont des uniformes très austères ça
rigole pas du tout polo blanc et bleu
petit pull avec un petit colevet
uniforme mixte donc aucune différence
effacement total de la différence et un
sondage il y a quelques mois en octobre
dernier disait tenez-vous bien que 68 %
de Français approuvent la tentation de
cette uniforme et c'est ça précisément
qui m'étonne que cette uniforme ne
suscite aucune indignation voire qu'il
soit salué comme une grande un grand
moment de retour de l'école républicaine
le plus drôle encore c'est que ce thème
de l'uniforme alors ça existe déjà mais
le moment où il s'est vraiment imposé
dans le débat public c'était en miroir
de la question de laba or justement ce
que les ennemis de les adversaires de la
BAA reprochait à ce vêtement outre qu'il
fut un vêtement à connotation cultuelle
c'était précisément d'être un uniforme
qui effaçait le corps et cetera et
cetera et donc là vous avez de
l'interdiction de la baaya à la
valorisation de l'uniforme un très bel
exemple de la logique de ce que derid le
philosophe appelait la logique de
l'auto-immunité c'est-à-dire en se
protengant contre un mal Ré ou fantasmé
et bien on institue on intériorise on
avale ce mal à l'intérieur même du corps
social bon quand même l'école c'est
c'est le lieu de l'acceptation
normalement de l'autorité non oui et
c'est précisément sur ce point que on en
est vraiment dans dans le caractère le
plus régressif de cette de cette mesure
en un sens très objectif il y a aucun
jugement de valeur régressif d'un point
de vue historique alors contrairement à
ce qu'on dit souvent il y avait pas
d'uniforme en France il y avait des
blouses des blouses depuis le 19e siècle
jusqu'aux années 70 donc en en gros
elles ont disparu après 1068 et ces
blues alors elles servaient à protéger
le vêtement pour pas que les enfants
salissent mais évidemment elles avaient
une fonction symbolique la symbolique
était celle de la discipline c'était de
faire en sorte que l'école soit un
appareil dont la finalité était la
contrainte créer plein de règles
arbitraires se lever devant le
professeur et cetera et cetera pour
montrer intérioriser un appareil de
pouvoir précisément tout l'héritage même
pas tellement de la pensée mais
davantage de l'esprit 68 c'était de dire
que l'école est certes un lieu de
contrainte mais dont le but est le de se
trouver de trouver sonp de de ciper de
trouver sa singularité de fabriquer sa
différence et c'est ça qu'on est en
train d'effacer dans l'indifférence la
plus générale et voilà un parti prix
particulièrement intéressant qui mérite
mais il en a quelques secondes une une
réaction le sociologue le regard de
gerérard Bronner sur l'uniforme bah
toutes les enquêtes montrent qu'il y a
un désir d'autorité chez les Français je
suis pas sûr que il s'incarne bien en la
matière de l'uniforme MOS 18 ans s été
sondé je sais pas ah oui alors ça je
peux vous le
direette les moins de 18 ans je peux
j'ai quelques exemples c'est non à
l'uniforme en tout cas vous vous
retrouvez sur la la dimension régressive
je retiens ce mot de l'uniforme merci
les affranchis Nathan de vert Yael gouse
Marco Pomier et Merci à VOUS Gérald
Brener exorcisme c'est à lire aux
éditions grass le parcours hallucinant
d'un grand chercheur sataniste au
départ universitaire respecté à
l'arrivée très belle soirée documentaire
avec Jean-Pierre gracien à demain
[Musique]